moi je trouve ça honteux en plus je suis
bordelais je connais très bien cette
cette cathédrale c'était qu'il entend
bien longtemps
à l'arrêt c'est pour mieux évasive un
donc je disais que c'était quand même
terme cette histoire et terry parce
qu'en plein écran c'est un monsieur
soi-disant qui a des troubles le
psychiatre et qui a craché idy qui ne
s'est pas rendu compte que c'était sur
un prêtre qui l'avait fait rare des
comédies tablier le prêtre on voit très
bien qui est habillé quand même pas être
pour autant le voilà on va rien regarder
l'envers c'est à dire que là-bas c'est
sûr que c'est pas un super il a dit je
savais pas que c'était un prêtre donc
voilà et lorsque je n'aime pas c'est
qu'elle a été sanctionné d'un stage de
citoyenneté c'est quand même quand même
une grosse connerie
s'agit citoyenneté vous retrouvez avec
14 personnes qui sont condamnées par
directement par le tribunal sans passer
par un jugement et c'est donc direct ils
se retrouvent justement on essaie de les
faire revenir dans le droit chemin etc
je n'y crois pas ce qui est dommage
c'est clair alors vous nous ayons nos
jeunes il ya un micro pour 10 personnes
dans la semaine il faut reparler on
l'entend avec son micro normal ou un
halo halo
est bon alors ce qui est dommage c'est
que la justice n'a pas le temps parce
que moi ce que j'aurais aimé c'est que
si cette personne elle est clairement
handicapé ben oui c'est pas de sa faute
si l avis de cracher sur tout le monde
dans la rue bah oui elle crache aussi
sur un prêtre mais après je pense qu'ils
n'ont pas eu le temps de faire toutes
ces recherches là donc si la personne
elle est handicapée bah oui juste un
truc comme ça ça suffit mais par contre
si c'est quelqu'un de conscience ou pour
moi je suis comme bernard c'est la
prison
il ya une altération du discernement il
ya une expertise psychiatrique kelly en
bonne et due forme et moi je trouve que
c'est très bien ça a été créé en 2004
c'est une alternative à la prison et on
va lui inculquer les valeurs de la
république
serait bien mes citations des
discernements
et alors le mettre en prison c'est
ridicule
c'est un monsieur handicapés faut pas le
mettre en prison et non plus à ça bien
sûr que ça va servir ce syndicat
enfin
crache sur les gens dont la
bonne voie à partir du moment où tout
comme comme l'a dit gilles et kelly à
partir du moment où il est lourdement
handicapé il sait pas il a pas eu
vraiment de discernement je pense que la
prison ne sert absolument à rien
effectivement je pense que whaou des
travaux d'intérêt général je pense que
ça peut servir et au moins ça cesse ça
sera beaucoup plus utile pour même pour
sa réinsertion en règle générale donc
voilà mais pas la prison je trouve ça
absurde alors moi l'altération du
comportement et du jugement je trouve ça
un peu facile en revanche effectivement
peut pas mettre quelqu'un présente pour
un crachat quand on voit un canton va
déjà notre système carcéral quand moi je
suis effectivement pour des travaux
d'intérêt général mais corse et une
surveillance corsé et une amende a fait
revivre le but d'une sanction c'est bien
que la personne ne recommence plus la
nausée quelqu'un qui est récidiviste qui
avait un couteau dans sa poche qui
crachent sur un prêtre est en lui mais
s'il est pas ça comment voulez que ça le
17 le micro ce pas pour le mettre
justement fois par mois par les moules
et que ça le 10 août de recommencer donc
voilà ça c'est le psychiatrique
s'épanouiront commence à chaque fois il
est resté défi comment là il s'est
enfermé maîtrise encore en prison et
qu'il aimerait que ses sentiments normal
justement les prix dans le problème
c'est qu'il ya des fous en même temps
que je me posais pas un bijou
donc ça donne un peu de prestance
maghrébin c'est vrai